hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in letter seven senica is going to
provide some advice to his interloc
lilius and he's going to say do you ask
ask what you should avoid more than
anything else a very smart question for
someone who wants to develop their
character and have a good life and you
know build a plan of life and senica
says one thing a crowd turam and so this
is a term for uh crowd you know but you
can think of it in terms of it's cogn
turbulent right people who are jostling
each other here and there and he's going
to talk about public spectacle and go
into right very graphic detail about
this that we'll get to shortly but we
could apply this to so many things in
our own time and culture because we
typically don't have Arenas filled with
deadly
gladiatorial shows but we have all sorts
of other things that can develop our
cruelty and inhumanity and wind up
making us more vicious people and notice
that Sena is not putting himself up on a
pedestal and saying yes young man you
must do these things that I did in my
own time senica says we're all still
invalids we're all still people who are
sick we're struggling and recovering
from a long illness what is this illness
it's taking place within us and it's
going to be The Vices which affect our
character character in this is
translating mores which means our habits
our dispositions the ways in which we
approach things and senica is going to
say it's not safe for you yet to trust
yourself to a crowd I'll admit my own
weakness in this regard and he says this
really fascinating thing never do I
return return home with the same
character I had when I left and
character there is moris so it's not as
if his entire character has changed but
the composite of these habits these
dispositions that have been developed it
might just be one that's changed a
little bit but that's enough to say I'm
losing something I'm losing some
progress when I do that he says always
there's something I had settled before
that is now stirred up again something
I'd gotten rid of that has returned and
he says contact
conversao with the many uh M right the
many people is harmful to us he's also
going to use the word a little bit later
uh public so we've got crowd many public
expressing the same basic idea and and
why is this the case well because we're
going to run into people who are going
to help produce bad things faults vices
vitium within us sometimes it will be by
urging some fault on us you know
actually advocating for something
sometimes it will be imparting a vice to
us and as he says sometimes a person
will even contaminate us without us
realizing it now contaminate ad linit or
Alit right which means to befoul to be
smirch so contaminating is is in the
sense of like smearing crap on you right
they've they've walked in dog poop or
something like that and they've you know
they've got it on their hand and they
put it on your shoulder you don't even
realize it but your clothes are now
gross right you're like
what's that smell well it's you because
you went out there into the crowd and
he's he's going to talk about several
different important factors here so one
of these is kind of a rule the larger
the group we associate with the greater
the
danger he doesn't explain why but we
could think about that well you know the
larger the group The more opportunities
you have to run into people who are
going to be a bad influence on you or
going to you know give you a bad example
but there's also something about the
social pressure of being in a large
group there's something
contagious about being part of as he's
going to say a public spectacle and you
know the example that he uses here again
very graphic I don't need to talk a lot
about this he says I found myself at the
midday show expecting some amusement or
wit something relaxing to give people's
eyes a rest from the sight of human
blood so there's been killings in the
ring before that and he's like H maybe
I'll you know see something that's not
that nope it's actually worse he says
the trifling was over now it was
unmitigated Slaughter instead of having
people with armor fighting against each
other or being thrown to beasts it's
people who are you know naked basically
with swords going at each other and the
cow cheering and yelling and wanting
them to to fight this is not good for
somebody but we could think about so
many other spectacles we don't as far as
I know I I won't speak for you go to
gladiatorial contests but there's so
many other things that we could easily
participate in that are not going to be
good for us in that respect so he says
nothing is as destructive as occupying a
seat in the public spectacle why because
the pleasure that we take in it lets the
fault slip in more easily so this is
another sort of rule or explanation
right when we're actually enjoying
ourselves it's easy to say oh it's just
this want it doesn't really affect me
I'm not going to be changed by this and
senica thinks that that is a foolish
thing to tell ourselves he says what do
you suppose I mean do I come home
greedier more power hungry more
self-indulgent worse I come home more
cruel and inhumane just because I've
been among these humans now he's talking
again about the gladiatorial show but
cruelty calitas is something that senica
thinks we have to
avoid now a little bit later he's going
to say um it's all too easy to follow
the
many even Socrates or KO or leus could
have had their character shaken out of
them by the multitude that was so
different so Socrates you know who he is
if you know anything about philosophy a
person of very high character you know
there's all sorts of stories about him
the stoics held him in high regard KO
was a Roman Statesman who was known for
not only being a stoic and participating
in the civil war against Julius Caesar
but for being basically unshakable not
only against Caesar but also against the
Tyrant solah before him if they'd hung
out with a crowd senica is saying their
character their morce their habits would
have inevitably been shaken so it's
better that they didn't do that and then
he says that goes all the more for us
you and me who are just beginning to
establish Inner Harmony we can't
withstand the attack of faults that
bring so much company along a single
example he says will do us harm and what
are the examples
self-indulgence greed being dissipated
with respect to lust uh a wealthy
neighbor inflames one
desires a spiteful companion infects the
most open and candid nature with his own
canker and then he says so if this is
going to happen with
individuals what do you think happens
with a character that's under attack by
the public at large and then he says You
must either imitate them or hate them so
there's two possible negative responses
imitate them because you get dragged
along and you get corrupted by the crowd
and is that a good thing to do no senica
says well don't imitate the bad because
they're
many the fact that there's a lot of them
doesn't mean that they're worthy of
imitation right
but you shouldn't have this counter
response of hating them either that's
actually not good for you hating not
just despising but hating Odis don't
become hateful to the many because
they're unlike you so don't turn
yourself into the wrong kind of elitist
we might say are there positive
responses that we can have in place of
these negative responses senica Not only
would it say yes but he advocates for
them and tells them what they are he
says Retreat into yourself as much as
you can so withdraw into you know we
sometimes talk about the inner Citadel
or a retreat within yourself so that's
important but that doesn't mean leave
everybody
behind why not because there should be
relationships and so he says spend time
with those who will improve you who will
make you better by their example by
their conversation by you know maybe
sometimes telling you you're you're
screwing up man right so spend time with
those who can make you
better
and you should spend time with some who
are not as good as you because you can
actually make them better in return
doesn't mean you should indiscriminately
take anybody in but he says extend a
welcome to those you can improve so if
you think that somebody could be helped
out let him in and then he says the
effect is reciprocal mut in this um
because people learn while teaching so
this is going to affect senaka
himself he is teaching lilius something
that he has learned but he's also learn
learning it while he's teaching and this
is where we get to something very
interesting Sena himself is in a certain
sense embodying this right so he says um
from whom did I learn these things you
don't have to worry that your time has
been wasted so long as you learn them
for yourself and then he says so that my
own learning today will not be for
myself alone I'm going to share three
exceptionally fine sayings that come to
mind
stuff that I've actually learned myself
as having some bearing on the point of
mind so he talks about democratus who
says one person counts as a nation with
me a nation as one person and then he
says there's a dispute about the second
one who the author is who when asked why
he expended such efforts over a work of
art very few could see you could think
about all the things that we do that
perhaps we think ah nobody's ever going
to notice this a few are enough one is
enough not even one is also enough and
then for the third he brings up epicurus
writing to one of his companions in
philosophy who says I write this not for
the many but for you you and I are
audience enough for one another and he
says okay lilus take these ideas to
heart and you know direct your goods in
word make this something for yourself so
that you don't need to seek out the
praise of the many and get distracted
and have your character worsened by your
Association your
involvement with them instead try to
have this positive response instead of
the negative responses and you will
thereby avoid the problems that come
about with others making you worse off
particularly when you put them all
together into a
crowd